i want to say something just
just one one thing about iron ranch uh
all my kids all my kids
read ein rand's books my father read the
fountain head i don't know like you know
like
we we know ein rand and um
i i'll tell you it is incredibly
difficult
reading for me it's it's painful it's
painful to read
why is it painful
not because i disagree with the uh with
with the view of of trading and business
and the creativity of it and and you
know and and reardon metal i mean you
know that stuff that stuff
moves me and and and and and i i do
admire it but
to read you know a book that's a
thousand pages long in which
nobody nobody is having children nobody
is having a stable marriage no one is
running a uh an admirable government
that's fighting for a just cause
anywhere anywhere euron i i i i feel i
just i feel like like
it's focusing on one aspect of what it
is to be human and to flourish and that
everything else is just erased and
thrown out as though it's just not part
of reality and i'm scared i'm scared of
what happens to to to teenagers who
hormonally or in any case know no that's
they're programmed to to uh to pull away
from their parents and experiment with
things they're
they're biologically programmed to do
that and you give them a book which says
look
you you don't you don't have to have a
family you don't have to raise children
you don't have to have a country you
don't have to fight for anything all you
have to do is
assert yourself and trade
i i think it's destructive because it's
not realistic it's just not real but i
got none of that for mine rent
i got none of that for mine man you know
the the the books were not about a
family uh you could write a book in in
iron man style about
where where people have a family but the
goal the purpose it's a novel it's not
it's a novel which is delimited with a
particular story there's one family in
goat's gulch and there's a little
passage about raising children and the
value of that uh because it's not court
to what she is writing about but that
doesn't exclude it i know when i read i
read i read out less when i was 16 and i
read it over over the years uh several
times more it never occurred to me oh
ain't han's anti-family i shouldn't have
a family it that that thought never came
into my mind i i always wanted to have
children i continued to want to have
children uh i i thought of it a little
differently i thought of how i would
find a partner a little bit differently
i thought about what i would look for in
a partner
differently but not that i wouldn't want
to get married
you